Ça va Léo?
Oui
Bienvenue dans ce premier épisode de "t'imagines si ?"
Merci
Eh bien, ça fait plaisir de t'avoir
Et on va parler sexe
J'ai posé une question aux gens
'fin, on y avait réfléchi ensemble
c'était: "T'imagines s'il n'y a plus d'hommes, plus de femmes
mais qu'on est tous ensemble un troisième sexe
un sexe unique, un sexe.
Ouais parce que dans les commentaires il y a eu pas mal de débats
sur le sexe, genre, etc.
Le sexe et le genre, c'est pas pareil;
le sexe, c'est la réalité biologique qui soutend nos identités
pour le dire "correctement".
Mais surtout ce qui définit, si l'on est un homme ou une femme
c'est le type de gamètes que l'on produit
donc si on fait des spermatozoïdes
ou si on fait des ovules, c'est surtout ça en fait le truc.
Avec toutes les exceptions qui existent,
parce qu'il y a plein de cas biologiques où les gens, bref.
Le genre, c'est la perception qu'on a de notre identité
dans le monde social.
En gros, c'est "est-ce que je me sens femme ou je me sens homme?"
Donc ça, ça peut être totalement déconnecté de la base biologique,
de si tu as un pénis ou un utérus.
Mais nous on ne parle pas de ça, on parle de sexe.
On ne parle pas de la perception sociale ou psychologique.
Les gens ont donné des pistes de réflexion
Et on va les lire ensemble
Y'a pas encore de générique mais ça arrive...
T'imagine s'il y avait un troisième sexe?
C'est pas faux
C'est quoi, s'il y a un troisième sexe?
Ca, je pense que c'est une vanne
parce que les escargots...
Non, non, le biologiste n'est pas d'accord
Le fait qu'il n'y ait plus de différences de sexe
en fait il n'y a plus de sexe (vu que le sexe se définit par plusieurs sexes)
J'sais pas si je suis clair là
Si tu as un seul sexe, il n'y a plus de sexes du tout.
On est d'accord?
Le sexe à la base, c'est du partage de gènes.
Les bactéries font du sexe, se refilent des gènes
"Eh! J'ai ça, j'ai celui-là, tu veux?"
et elles se les passent par des pilli
ce sont des tubes et une bactérie se connecte à une autre par ce genre de tube
Tu as l'image?
Et du coup, les gènes se trimbalent à travers le tube
et l'autre bactérie reçoit les gènes. Ca, c'est du sexe.
Le sexe chez nous
Il y a un mâle, une femelle, deux types différents de gamètes
Les hermaphrodites ont aussi deux types différents de gamètes
Hermaphrodite?
les escargots, par exemple...
Moi je sais, c'est pour les gens.
...des animaux qui peuvent changer de sexe.
genre les huitres?
J'en ai aucune idée.
Je pensais que les huitres pouvaient.
Ces exemples là, je n'y connais rien
Je ne connais rien en biologie en fait.
Tu as des animaux qui changent de sexe au cours de leur vie
ou qui peuvent se reproduire avec d'autres. Les escargots peuvent faire ça?
Je ne sais pas si c'est toutes les espèces d'escargots, parce qu'il y en a quand même pas mal
mais oui, ils sont connus pour ça.
T'imagine si on était tous d'un même sexe, genre d'un sexe unique?
Ce serait ouf nan?
in-croy-able
Non, ça va.
avec un "s"
Le gros connard tu sais
"plein de fautes là-dedans."
Les positions sexuelles, ça c'est drôle ça.
Ca dépend vraiment de la gueule qu'aurait ce troisième sexe.
Si on a les mêmes anatomies ce serait peut-être moins riche, non?
Faudrait regarder si les homosexuels ont moins de positions que les hétéros.
Y'aurait sans doute un organe pour mettre à l'intérieur et un organe pour recevoir.
Faut qu'on garde notre cul.
Absolument quoi
Faut qu'on garde l'anus
Oui, mais ça c'est pas lié au sexe, c'est lié à la digestion.
gardons un trou quoi.
Ouais mais genre même deux trous, si les deux trous sont difficiles à atteindre
c'est compliqué tu vois.
Putain, peut-être qu'il n'y aurait pas tant de positions que cela en fait.
Ce ne serait peut-être même pas jouissif en fait
Les vagins, ça marche parce que c'est facilement accessible,
et donc elles peuvent frotter leurs vagins par exemple.
Tu vois ce que je voulais dire?
Imagine si ça n'était que l'anus, notre partie sexuelle
et genre faudrait se frotter l'anus...Hyper galère
Un cloaque en fait. Chez les oiseaux, c'est comass.
Mais il est accessible? Nous, notre anus il a quand même des bonnes fesses.
Bah les fesses disparaîtraient.
Les fesses donc disparaîtraient?
On ferait comment pour s'asseoir du coup?
Les fesses servent aussi à la locomotion
Tu as besoin d'avoir de gros muscles, de grosses cuisses pour marcher.
Est-ce que par exemple le pénis disparaîtrait?
Si on a juste besoin de s'échanger du matériel génétique,
parce qu'on a quand même besoin de s'échanger du matériel génétique,
pour perdurer
En vrai, c'est que ça le sexe.
C'est juste créer des trucs nouveaux pour éviter que tout le monde meurt si un parasite qui arrive
Du coup on aurait plus besoin du pénis?
Soit tout le monde a, et un pénis et un vagin
pour à la fois se faire pénétrer et pénétrer
ou alors on a plus qu'un truc
qui nous permette de s'accoller et de s'échanger des gènes
putain, énorme
Ou alors des gens pondent des oeufs et d'autres s'assoient dessus
et récupèrent les oeufs, pleins de gènes...
Tu peux imaginer des trucs hein!
Il y a pas mal d'exemples dans le vivant de trucs assez sympas.
Voilà, comme les bactéries, on se fait un petit pili sexuel
Toi tu m'en envoies un.
En fait, ça pourrait être genre un câble qu'on achète...
Un  usb quoi!
Est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un porno avec ce câble, qu'on insèrerait...
Est-ce que tu imagines s'il n'y avait qu'un troisième sexe?
A chaque fois, c'est "pu" d'enfants
Y'a pas le "l" hein
Je lis comme c'est écrit.
En fait, c'est qu'on a tendance à croire
que le sexe est forcément obligatoire pour faire de la reproduction, et c'est pas le cas.
Le sexe, c'est une invention, il n'y avait pas de sexe avant.
Qui qui a inventé le sexe?
Il est incroyable ce mec... ou cette meuf!
Exactement!
C'est Marie Curie,
Okay, balèze
qui a aussi inventé le curry.
La meuf qui a tout fait quoi.
Les deux meilleures choses de l'humanité le curry et le sexe.
Est-ce qu'elle a inventé les bains-marie aussi?
...au curry?
Il faut s'arrêter là.
Pourquoi est-ce que le sexe c'est agréable?
C'est que c'est une récompense qui est évidente
C'est à dire...Imagine un monde dans lequel tous les gens qui se reproduisent...
...ils trouvent ça chiant de se reproduire tu vois.
C'est pas agréable
Et là, d'un coup tu as un mec qui naît avec une mutation qui rend le sexe hyper agréable.
Mais alors lui il va passer sa vie à faire ça!
La vie trouve son chemin...
Et ils ont dépensé sans compter.
C'est une autre phrase de Jurassik Park.
T'imagine si genre on était pas homme ou femme mais un troisième sexe, un sexe unique!
Je pense que c'est à peu près vrai
Bon, le plaisir, les circuits de la récompense tout ça, c'est juste chez ceux qui ont un système nerveux,
donc une toute petite partie du monde vivant en fait.
Les plantes n'ont pas forcément d'orgasmes ou de récompenses, du moins pas que je sache.
Mais bon, clairement elles le font, donc ça marche aussi, bon bref.
Je chipote.
La vie trouve toujours son chemin.
Ils ont dépensé sans compter.
T'imagines si il n'y avait plus qu'un troisième sexe?
Ah putain, c'est une bonne question ça.
Eh ben je pense...
On aurait plus les féministes, mais on trouverait autre chose, on trouverait toujours des trucs pour discriminer.
T'imagine si, y avait plus qu'un troisième sexe?
Je sais pas si t'as pas envie de niquer ta mère même si ta mère est pareille que toi?
Je vois pas trop pourquoi ça changerait en fait?
Et en plus tu pourrais niquer ton père, parce qu'il est pareil!
Si ça se trouve on dit de la merde. C'est possible.
Allez voir les chaînes de psychologie, type "le PsyLab" et ce commentaire a été écrit par "Psynect"..
...qui a lui-même une chaîne de psychologie.
et qui est même vachement bien.
T'es quelqu'un de bien.
T'imagine si, genre il y avait un troisième sexe, un sexe unique!
C'est énorme. Déjà merci, merci beaucoup pour ce commentaire. C'est cool!
Mais alors attends...
Donc là c'est dans le cas où ça se passerait d'un claquement de doigt quoi?
Franchement, je ne suis même pas sûr que, comme il dit, les manifestants gays
manifestent leur joie.
Je pense que personne ne serait content en fait.
L'aspect le plus intéressant là, c'est vraiment le côté économique, est-ce qu'on serait tous plus riches?
Moi je pense que oui.
Ah ouais, pourquoi?
Je pense que le féminisme...euh le sexisme coûte très cher.
Oulala, le lapsus oulala....CHAAAUD
Y a une bonne moitié de la population qui est sous-utilisée, en fait
Qui est sous-payée, tu peux dire ?
Bah sous-payée et puis en fait, quand tu sous-payes quelqu'un, il...
Tu le payes moins bien, tu le formes moins bien, enfin,
y a la moitié des cerveaux de, de, du monde qui sont moins bien formé que l'autre moitié
et, c'est débile, 'fin tu pourrais avoir tellement plus de génies...
...et en plus, on parle pas de petits écarts,
en France, l'écart entre les salaires homme/femme à poste égal c'est 19%.
Ah ouais, 19 ? Ouais, j'avais entendu beaucoup parler de 30%,
mais je sais pas dans quel domaine, dans quel secteur...
...moi j'ai vu ça, j'ai vu ça sur France Infos y a pas longtemps.
De plus avoir de sexe, donc de plus avoir de sexisme,
je pense que ça générerait énormément de tunes, en fait.
Je pense pas qu'on recréera les hommes et les femmes.
Surtout si c'est un truc qui a jamais existé avant, tu vois.
Ouais là, non mais là c'était dans le cas où ça existait.
Dans le cas où ça existe... Bah peut-être les premières générations, les gens essayeront
quand même absolument de trouver une différence de genre, parce qu'ils sont habitués mais...
Mais genre, genre "- T'aimes le rose ? - Euh, ouais, et alors... ? - Ok, -19% sur le salaire."
Mais ça, ça dura quoi ? 50 ans ? 200 ans ? On s'en fout quoi, c'est...
Une paille à l'échelle évolutive quoi, donc voilà.
Une chasse d'eau.
Une chasse d'eau, paille.
Pa-paille.
T'imagines si, genre, on était un sexe unique, tous.
Ouais.
Ensemble
Ça on l'a évoqué déjà.
Y compris en Antarctique où les manchots sont blancs/noirs, ouais.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, on va continuer du coup.
T'imagines si genre, euh, y avait pas d'hommes, de femmes et qu'en fait genre, on était un troisième sexe
genre un sexe unique quoi, t'imagines ?
Oh nan !
T'imagines le truc de ouf ?
Olala !
T'imagines !
[bruitage d'explosions]
Alors, réponse de John Deuf.
Oui, oui !
Ça c'est l'omelette.
Euh non parce que bah, y a du porno avec des gens qui ont le même sexe, du coup...
Du porno avec des gens pareils ça existe déjà et ça se vent très bien donc
je vois pas pourquoi ça marcherait plus si tout le monde est pareil.
Mais, là c'est intéressant
Alors, non, parce que en fait...
...le mec a tout faux en fait.
Non.
John Deuf, tu t'es embrouillé.
Oui, oui !
Il a fait un plat
Oui, oui ! Le mec est chaud, le mec est chaud !
Attends, il est poché
Il, il l'a ou pas ?
Il a la coque ?
Ah !
Les MST c'est quoi ? C'est des parasites, des virus, des champignons,
la chlamydia c'est des champignons.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut penser que ça existerait plus ?
On continuerait de se reproduire.
Justement, chez des levures, t'as pas de différence, y a pas de sexe, en fait,
y a pas de mâles/femelles, y a juste des individus qui sont tous pareils et qui fusionnent
et ils font quand même, ils font quand même du sexe, c'est-à-dire, ils font quand même
de l'échange génétique même si il y a pas de sexe, même si il y a pas de mâles
et femelles.
Et chez ces levures là, y a quand même, elles ont quand même des parasites
Elles ont quand même des virus parce que les virus c'est quoi ?
C'est un truc qui va t'attaquer pour pouvoir survivre.
Bah même si on s'échange des gênes, mais même si y a plus de mâle/femelle
ça existera quand même quoi, donc y aura toujours des MST.
Est-ce que je suis claire ?
C'est très très claire.
Et justement d'ailleurs.
Et je suis entrain de me rendre compte qu'en fait, cette émission, en fin, ce format,
c'est genre, j'ai l'impression d'être auste. Genre, j'accueille quelqu'un et j'apprends en même temps.
Je là, "humm, intéressant".
Clairement, y aura encore des MST, déso'.
Déso' no déso'.
Ça fait partie de la vie aussi.
De l’herpès...
Même si la vie trouve toujours un chemin.
Mais ils ont dépensé sans compter.
Ouais.
- Ça t'as plu, mec, ou pas ? - Carrément.
- C'est vrai ? - Carrément.
T'as passé un bon moment ?
Oui.
Ça fait plaisir.
Carrément.
Ça fait vachement plaisir !
Ouais, c'était bien !
Ok, cool.
Je reviendrai.
C'est vrai ?
Ouais !
Eh ben, vas-y, bah, je t'inviterai.
Allez !
Avec plaisir, avec plaisir !
On trouvera un autre thème, un autre thème sympas.
Merci ! Merci beaucoup pour toutes vos questions, enfin toutes vos réponses plutôt.
C'était vachement pertinent, vachement intéressant, y avait pas mal de trie à faire
du coup on s'est bien marré, y avait des trucs drôles, enfin, c'était, c'était très cool !
Et vous avez vachement bien joué le jeu et ouais c'était pertinent, donc merci et bravo !
Ouais, c'était vraiment cool, les commentaires sont sympas et hyper constructifs, du coup.
C'est une bonne émission...
Pouce en l'aire !
...que tu vas faire là
C'est vrai ?
Ouais je pense, ouais.
Bah j'espère aussi, j'espère aussi. C'est en train de prendre forme, un petit peu....
Et comme je te disais hors caméra, c'est aussi avec la manière dont on a interagit ensemble,
Ouais.
que ça impacte un petit peu.
Qui va définir le truc, ouais.
Ouais, c'est un truc qui se définit un peu par lui-même.
Le prochain d'ailleurs, ce sera avec Dr. Nozman
Yes.
Et je vais vous poser la question dès maintenant :
Répondez-y dans les commentaires de la vidéo, sur YouTube.
Voilà, ce sera que les commentaires de la vidéo sur YouTube, ok ?
Donc répondez-y à fond, jouez le jeu à fond et c'est grâce à vous que ce format peut exister
A plus, bisous, ciao, bye-bye !